back in this country the green New Deal
almost overnight it seems like has taken
over the environmental agenda of the
Democratic Party on pioneer Alexandria
Kazuya Cortez says we're gonna need to
ground our planes ditch our cars stop
having kids for the sake of the planet
we even need to stop eating hamburgers
though cause you of Cortez his chief of
staff was just caught downing one for
dinner the other night
but even if we went entirely to wind and
solar as the green New Deal ordains
would that fix the problems we need to
fix michael Shellenberger has spent many
years looking at this and he doesn't
think so he's the president of the group
environmental progress and he joins us
tonight Michael thanks very much for
coming on
you wrote a piece in quill up this
morning that I thought was really smart
and interesting I recommend it to
everyone watching because of the level
of scientific detail in it but it's
about wind and solar and the claim that
we could shift the grid to rely on
renewables like wind and solar overnight
and be okay and you say that's not
possible yeah we you know and I was one
of the founders of sort of the original
green new deal back in 2000 between 2003
2007 people don't remember President
Obama we spent about 150 billion dollars
on renewables between 2009 and 2015 and
we just kept encountering the same kind
of problems everywhere that were related
both to the the essential unreliability
of solar and wind
they just depend on when the Sun is
shinin and wind is blowing which is 10
to 40 percent of the year and then also
something that people are not as aware
of which is the low energy density of
sunlight and wind and basically what
we've been finding is that the the lower
the energy density of the fuel in this
case the sunlight wind the bigger the
environmental impact you just have to
use a lot more natural resource
including land to generate very much
electricity so it's not very good for
the environment was your point then you
point to another form of energy that has
a checkered reputation but that you made
a very powerful case for nuclear yeah I
mean we were in the in the process of
trying to figure out how to deal with
things like climate change or even if
you're not as concerned about climate
change how to deal with air pollution
yes we finally just had a number of
friends who said what
about nuclear and we were like well but
nuclear is scary and we had you know I
had all of the concerns that most people
have about nuclear I went up read up
about all the accidents and was shocked
actually about how few people died in
Chernobyl in the most recent accident
Fukushima the scientists agree that
nobody will die from the radiation that
escaped and that too is explained by the
energy density so what we find is that
biomass burning wood and fossil fuels
kill about seven million people a year
from smoke and so that smoke is just a
function of all of that waste product
being in the air people breathing it
with nuclear even in the worst accident
only a tiny amount of material escapes
and so the energy density of the fuel
also determines just how much air
pollution there's going to be so the
people who wrote the green new deal and
proposals like it must have consulted
scientists before they did and so they
must know what you just said is true
because it demonstrably is true so why
is it new why isn't nuclear part of the
solution why they against nuclear it's
very disappointing well I mean there's
sort of three big reasons why people are
against nuclear I mean the first is that
they associated with the bomb which is
wrong there are two separate
technologies you know the second is that
in the 60s more in the 60s but still
around today there was concerns that too
much cheap energy too much nuclear
energy would result in overpopulation
overconsumption and then the third one
which in some ways is the most powerful
is just a really strong desire to use
energy to harmonize with the natural
world that turns out to be a bad idea
because the more the more natural
resource we use the worse it is for the
natural environment
you know exactly exist were unfortunate
at a time I would recommend your piece
on quill out to everybody watching
because it really changed my mind
completely on the subject like shale
burger thank you very much thanks for
having me